this is the bismillah hamdulillah Salaam
alaikum peace be on to you thank you for
tuning in to the Deen show and this week
we want to help all of those people that
are suffering suffering and have some
sadness in the heart there's it there's
a void that needs to be filled and you
know what you're doing your best you
striving you're striving to submit to
the one God you're striving to do good
deeds you're striving to develop
yourself to have noble character but you
might have lost a loved one you might
have separated in a marriage you might
just be having a bad month or a bad week
and you just sad so how do we as Muslims
those who have submitted to the one God
how do we deal with that even if you're
a not yet Muslim and you're going
through depression this is a topic for
you too and we're gonna be covering this
with our next guest Yasser fours Agha
sit tight we'll be right back this is
the team
this is the thesis betangel
Salam alaikum peace be with you
well it comes to our home - like a
bucket how are you sure
I'm doing good I'm the how you Eddie
good hamdulillah all thanks as the
creator of the heavens and earth who's
given us this ability to be here I'm
very thankful time is short
so let's get right into the topic I
opened it and you are the director of
the Mental Health Institute so you deal
a lot with people coming in and having a
bad day having a bad month having a bad
year and they're depressed is this right
that is very right and again I really
have to thank you Eddie for bringing up
these topics these are real issues that
people have to go through every single
day and actually the Quran makes it very
clear that by the mere fact that we are
humans we are going to face challenges
in our lives we don't get to choose the
timing of the challenge we don't get to
choose the nature of the challenge or
where it may happen but the fact remains
and that is we will face some challenge
in our lives that challenge may be us
our wealth our health it may be our
loved ones those who are around us and
again was these challenges it's not just
the loss but also it is the impact that
the loss may have upon us like you said
you know depression just happens to be
one of these challenges that may face us
as humans now keep in mind that
depression is not necessarily a
character weakness people would deem
depression to be come and just try and
you know to shake people out of it you
know and they would give you that pep
talk when going gets tough the tough get
going
yeah-oh hard times don't last but tough
people do but these are beautiful words
but they really do not eliminate
depression so depression is not seen as
a personal weakness of the individual so
please if you know anybody that is
depressed
they make sure that you do not attribute
depression to their weakness because
it's not depression also is not the
result of weak faith and that is
something that we hear amongst religious
groups and that is all the persons faith
in God is not that strong that is why
they are depressed and that is not real
what it really is is that at this point
the pain that you are going through is
so overwhelming and you do not have
enough tools to deal with the pain so
you go into depression that's basically
in simple words that is really what it
means so appreciate that you bringing up
this topic but it's also very important
that we know how to characterize it the
right way so that we become a source of
empowerment to those who are around us
rather than a source of depression to
those who are already on depressed so I
will appreciate you bringing up this on
this topic not only that but also this
idea that religious people are not
necessarily what we call inherently
protected from becoming depressed simply
because they are religious reality is
depression is something that you know it
it crosses all bounce and all you know
socioeconomic um ethnic religious none
of that matters we're all prone to it
now what Islam promises is this Islam
does not say that because you are a
Muslim you will never be depressed Islam
says that because you are a Muslim you
have access to the tools that Islam
gives you if you're depressed it will
prevent you from going into despair so
religion prevents despair it does not
prevent inherently it does not prevent
depression that's a key right there so
being the press is a part of the natural
just consequence of being a human being
and not only that but if we are not
depressed there is really something
wrong I mean chances are we will be
depressed someday it will be a new minor
depression it may be major depression
but definitely we will have the blues
you know when you have one day we're
just not feeling well
down so that is that is human and we
embrace this we don't try to rush
ourselves out out of it but remember
it's not depression that bothers us
it is the consequences of depression how
people choose to cope with depression
what people and who people become as a
result of depression that is really the
challenge now you also said after
depression the this way of life it will
keep you from going into despair right
because what happens when you go into
despair
that's when people go into suicide that
is people want or go on - it's not worth
living anymore that is when people
literally give up and they give up on
life that is dangerous so that is where
we come in with the tools that Islam
says that we have so that it prevents
that well I'll just give you a give you
an example Eddie did you know that every
15 minutes in the u.s. somebody takes
away their own life every 15 minutes
every 15 minutes that is 90 people a day
that is 34,000 people every year they
died because of suicide falling in
despair now yes not only that Eddie but
it is the third leading cause for people
between the ages of eight between the
age of 18 and 45 and it's the second
leading cause of death for college
students we're talking about a serious
serious problem here it's not just the
depression that is serious it is the
consequences how people cope and how
people deal with depression that is
problematic people who go into alcohol
thinking that this is going to make them
you know forget about their problems
that is something that started with
depression but now the coping mechanism
the coping skills that the person has
acquired are so poor that depression is
no longer the problem it is the way that
they are dealing with depression people
who go into smoke and especially
nowadays the smoking pot is so
unbelievably popular because that is the
only way that a person has learned how
to cope was their depression and that is
really sad so what we're after here is
to be depressed is
human to go into despair is unacceptable
so it is helping the individuals who are
going through these tough times you know
deal with the depression getting out of
it but at the same time we don't want
them to go into disappear as well
usually like when you get hurt okay you
you you get a bandaid on the scar it
takes a few days maybe a week
you broke a bone it takes a little bit
of longer but the emotional scar
sometimes can take even longer than the
physical scars but is there you've been
an expert in this area is there
approximately about a time if you you
know in a way these tools you mentioned
that if you deal with it it maybe take
em off for six months how long does it
or is there even such a thing that
approximately you'll feel this this
depression emptiness and before it goes
away yeah well a person is considered to
be clinically depressed if they have had
six of nine symptoms and it's very
quickly feeling fatigued a sense of
hopelessness losing interest
seeking isolation thinking about death a
person not finding pleasure in
pleasurable things that they have done
in the past a person feeling down most
of the day very little tolerance for
irritants the whole idea of feeling down
so if you have had this for two weeks
then you are considered to be clinically
depressed now this is not considering
that a major life-changing event has
taken place people getting divorced a
loved one dying then we would expect
that naturally it would take us some
time to heal but if you are depressed
and you have been there for a while then
two weeks would be you know anything
less than two weeks would be normal more
than two weeks it would be clinically
you are defined as clinically depressed
let's take a break and we right back
with more here in the Dean show
you will not feel a woman do not kill a
child do not you know going to different
religions Buddhism in division forms of
Christianity I even ran it to people
from the Nation of Islam feeling a man
you will not feel an animal you will not
cut a tree down do not tell me the water
will not burn their homes back here on
the Dean show with che Yossef is Agha
we're talking about depression and we
want people to understand ok this is
normal but when you fall into what are
you talking about now desperation or
what was the other word the poor coping
mechanism to dissipate all despair ok
when you fall into despair that can be a
problem leading to suicide and things
that you know taking the wrong course
now but tell us ok so a broken bronc can
tell you ok and in six months you'll be
healed you mentioned two weeks before we
went to the break and then you're you're
clinically diagnosis as depressed right
so how is it so from here after you
you've been depressed for two weeks
I mean talk to us more is there like
after two months that it gets your label
something else or should it go away
after two months but do you have to be
doing something these tools you
mentioned what are the tools and do you
have to implement them how do you
implement them otherwise you're
depressed for two years
yeah see think about depression like
falling into a hole
Eddy okay and this is for the viewers as
well but that hole is not stagnant the
hole is either getting deeper or you're
trying to crawl out of it and the longer
that we stay in that hole the deeper it
gets but also the deeper it gets the
more difficult it gets to get out of it
and the more hopeless we become as a
result so usually what we want to see is
that once a person recognizes this that
they're depressed and we usually do and
then again you know depending on the
severity of it so we would say that a
person is depressed it's either you know
minor depression it is or it's mild they
would call it
it's either moderate
or it is severe and when it gets severe
we're talking a person being negligent
of their personal hygiene
for example they don't go to work
anymore their performance is just um and
their functionality is impacted by this
they started performing very poorly
academically in their relationship they
start neglecting their responsibilities
towards their loved ones and that's when
like they can have like suicidal
thoughts or they can actually start
having psychosis which means that you
know their perception of reality is
disturbed at this at this point so what
we are looking at is we want to make
sure that the minute we notice it then
we want to make sure that we take early
prevention so the very first tool that I
would you know point our attention to is
this whole idea of early prevention if
you detect it if you sense it do
something about it
and basically because depression is all
about doing nothing just people idling
and you know there is really nothing
happening the very first thing that we
want to do is actually begin by doing so
doing something as opposed to doing
nothing exactly and the point is that
this helps people in really getting out
of it remaining to be functional despite
the fact that they are depressed now you
know there is this thing about being an
alcoholic and a functioning alcoholic
you can be depressed and functionally
you're also you know you're you're okay
it's a lesser form of depression at that
at that point we also want to make sure
that you surround yourself with a good
support system that is when family
members come in that is when friends
coming you know you're talking about
people who have committed suicide okay
they say that about 80% of the people
before they you know before they
completed their suicide they called them
loved one they called their loved one
okay there was this a story about this
young man he was determined and San
Francisco that he was going to go to the
Golden Gate Bridge and that he was going
to throw himself down unless somebody
asks about him so he said that he
actually made
to the Golden Gate Bridge and said that
a couple came and they handed him a
camera and asked if he can take their
photo they said I took their photo but
they did not ask how I was doing hmm so
he threw himself down but he did not die
and that's how we know the story so the
idea is that even when people are
depressed and they get into that state
of despair and they no longer want to
live they usually reach out to somebody
before before they do that so if you are
a parent and your teenage son or
daughter the been talking to you about
depression please take that seriously if
you're a friend and somebody has reached
out to you saying that I really don't
want to live anymore please take that
seriously when there is a course that we
teach on just noticing signs and
symptoms of a person considering suicide
people giving their valuables away
people have this cat that they really
adore and they call you up and say no I
want you to take care of my cat Oh for
the weekend and no no I won't take I
want you to take care of it you mean are
you leaving town no I just want you to
have it immediately know what is what is
going on when people start giving you
know away things that they really value
it means that they're clearing the way
to do that
so this is support system you know and
don't be afraid of asking people you
know what you're very depressed you know
I'm really afraid for you and do not be
afraid of using the word suicide
are you considering suicide don't shy
away from using uh from using the word
you're normalizing it at that at that
point so it will be it will be these
things you know the support systems and
then there's just the proper tools
having access to a professional is
definitely a tool that we want you to
employ and remember because you're
seeing a therapist or you're seeing a
psychiatrist
it does not mean that it you are weak
because you are unable to do it on your
on your own it does not mean that you're
crazy
it does not mean that you are insane and
I know that you know therapists don't
really fare well in society nowadays
especially if you're a psychiatrist
people are talking about you visiting a
shrink and so so there is that stigma
that that that comes um that comes with
it but just get to know as many tools as
as possible and you know we've mentioned
three of them here um so far so don't be
alone talk to someone get attention for
this matter right away yes an early
early detection early prevention is
usually the way to go talk to us about
some other things that a person can do
you know to get more optimistic on the
optimistic side and to get away from you
know falling into despair they lost
let's say they just got divorced or you
know the person lost their children you
know some things other things that you
recommend that they do you know one
great tool that we really like to do is
something that we call real labeling and
basically what that is is that you're
not necessarily changing the facts of
what happened but just give it a
different label and that may actually
make you feel better so we can refer to
somebody as either a rape victim or a
rape survivor we're not changing the
facts you know something bad has really
happened to this person something
terrible has happened to this person but
when I call them a victim it's a downer
yet when I use the word survivor there's
actually hope they're empowering the the
the individual so rather than saying
that I am weak for example let's say
when you're depressed I know I'm going
through some difficult times at this
point and what that would do is that
just the negative labeling of the self
is removed away and that actually helps
us in keeping our own sense of goodness
our self-concept our sense of self has
not been distorted as a result of this
negative label that we have applied to
our army to ourselves reaching out to
friends usually it's just the support
system that is around us you know making
sure that you are in good company there
will be such a great tool as is I mean
good friends good friends are beautiful
asset you know and that's why you know
say that that's the best you know the
most beautiful things in life are not
things
it is relationships and what better and
more beautiful than a relationship that
you can actually count on when you are
so down down our friends we're gonna
take a break and we'll be right back
with more
here on today's show I am I am not
afraid to stand alone if you live by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if a box by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if a box
beside I am Not Afraid
I solo on Dios
Herrera solo yeah na seuk lesson I would
go to my room lock the door
go straight and class ain't God you know
me better than myself show me the right
way and I will not look to how we leave
everything behind a lot of that grader
and he creates everything intelligent to
people back here on the Dean show
woodshed Yossef Isaiah now in this way
of life that we follow the way of life
of all the messengers of God we're
trying to live a righteous life
according to God's will is not our
desires sometimes a person can get more
depressed feeling that you know what is
it's a punishment from God and my
discipline did I do something to
displease God can a person sins also you
know going away from let's say the
prayer you know establishing a
relationship with the Creator can this
also lead to depression or even on the
flipside if someone's doing these things
but then they fall into depression they
feel like you know what is God turn his
back on me and they get more depressed
you know here's what we say having the
correct perception of who God is and
knowing him through his names and
attributes and the beautiful qualities
that he has told us about it's just a
Cardinal Cardinal component of having a
healthy life the other thing that you
also want to keep in mind is if if the
higher the gap between where we actually
are and our values and principles
meaning that if our values and
principles are up here and our actions
are down here this is too high of a gap
and that is an invitation to misery we
are actually happiest when there is
harmony between what we believe what our
principles are what our values are and
then our actions are actually a
testimony to what we believe in what we
value and what our principles are so
what we want to do is close this gap as
much as possible and that is harmony
that is when we acquire that peace of
mind you know the saying that if what
you believe in there's not impact how
you behave then what you believe in is
not important so how can you say that
God is merciful yet you have this
perception of him saying that God opens
the doors and he is the dispenser of
grace yet you say that so that would be
an erroneous and erroneous
perception of God because God does not
benefit anything from putting us through
miseries that will not be acceptable
does prayer does getting close to God
help it definitely does and that is why
many times actually a therapist would
refer clients for some spiritual healing
you know they would say fine I want you
to take your medication
take your antidepressants or
anti-anxiety pills I want you to come to
counseling so that we make sense out of
it but you know what I think spiritual
healing will also be helpful to you so
you see a lot of people being sent to
their rabbi to their pastor to their
Imams and the point is a spirituality
can actually add meaning and give
explanation to what the person is going
through as well as the idea of
instilling hope because of the belief in
God that can also be a very important
component of you know gaining back our
emotional health now before we close
just a few more points that I want to
cover now there's a person who is who's
living more of a life according to this
way of life according to the game plan
well that person that be less inclined
towards depression here's the thing what
that's really about what causes
depression yeah so it could be the
genetics it could be the biological
factors it could be environmental it
could be just the other person's own
susceptibility to fall into depression
so you may really be praying and what
have you but then you lose a child so
naturally you would be that's just
natural now you you shouldn't feel
guilty about you get divorced yeah so
naturally you would feel that because
you are religious like we said religion
does not inherently present depression
religion gives you enough tools to
prevent you from going into this pain
the tool so you can do the job when the
depression kicks in you got the tools to
help you get out of it exactly exact if
you don't have the tools and the tools
would you say the knowledge or the tools
would be you know what we call about you
know just the whole idea of being aware
that the idea of optimism because
optimism believe it or not is actually a
learned behavior gotcha we're not born
optimistic it's a learned behavior it's
a behavior that we actually learn you
know attitude and perception all these
things this would be proper tools that
we can all learn and the thing is Eddie
and this is really interesting um each
and every one of us we have got like
just enough well of treasure within us
that we have not tapped into so if you
go to a good therapist what that
therapist would do they won't really
give you new tools but they would tap
into your own well of tools that you
actually have but you were not aware now
last closing comments or suggestions for
the person's is at the edge they're at
the edge you know what and they might
even be contemplating suicide and they
just tune into the Dean show and they're
listening to you what advice do you have
for you know I look you know this idea
of of you being depressed that is not a
personal weakness it's not a lack of
faith it is just what it is so you know
the pain is overwhelming at this point
and what you need is tools to help you
you know get out of the pain please
reach out your friends call a hotline
you know talk to your family doctor talk
to your family family members just do it
for your own self as well and you know
what if we can last this day we never
know the goodness that tomorrow is going
to bring to us and that's the whole idea
of just you know seeing the light at the
end of the tunnel you know and and and
the sad reality is you know a bend in
the road is not necessarily the end of
the road so it may just be that terrain
that you need and then you will see the
light at the end of it thank you thank
you so much and again we started with
peace we I'm with peace thank you so
much may God Almighty the creator reward
you for being with us I mean think and
thank you for a sin tight to another
episode of these are some great advice
some great advice from the experts and
that's why you come here too
learn to learn every week we're here
trying to bring you another episode and
if you want to learn more about the most
misunderstood way of life yet the
fastest-growing Way of life and this way
of life will bring nothing but joy and
peace into one's life but you've got to
have the tools and one of the first
tools to start with and you can get it
for free is by calling the 1 800 662
Islam number that's the verbatim Word of
God
that's right it's the Koran so if you'd
like to get your copy give us a call
today and for any questions that you
might have even criticisms are welcome
we can start a healthy dialogue that's
right and I'll see you next time here in
the den show until then peace be unto
you and if we're gonna worship something
I figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the religions
I remember finding out the meaning of
what Islam is what most limits those who
surrender their self to cut is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid